hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics rationally that does physics at
all you know for that matter uh we got a
great day today so let's see if we can
get directly into it uh I'm going to
start a little bit with our Extinction
segment and uh related questions okay so
here's the first one uh fellow ask the
following and I'm gonna try to answer
him he says uh I wish M you spelled that
misspell that I wish Mee the best of the
best but it will be very hard people
there in Argentina right he's the
president of
Argentina uh don't know how to live
without government help then he
continues and he says uh what do you
think will happen in the US this year
year with presidential
elections okay first let me clarify
something about uh M's last name someone
asked about that m in Spanish M if you
separate those two words uh stands for
my law that's direct except that M his
last name is with I whereas my law m
stands goes with a Y okay that's the
only difference but the prounciation is
the same so m stands for my law and I
guess yeah he did it his
way okay just so you know anyways I
don't care about politics not into
politics for many many years now got out
of politics
uh um you know you learn a lot over time
and uh politics is essentially opinion
okay it's opinion and therefore uh
opinion what is opinion opinion is
religion you you know uh just belief
someone person has one belief or or
another or you have recommendations for
how the world should be run etc etc and
they go with this guy because they think
that person is gon to deliver what he
thinks is the ideal situation or the the
ideal politics or whatever and you know
I'm I'm way out of that completely today
I don't get involved into choos sides or
any of that what I do is essentially say
you know um I I work at it the other way
around first of all I only look at
politics in relation to and economics in
relation to Extinction okay that's
that's the first thing but then the
other one is that um I don't say this is
what we should do this is what is good
or Etc or bad or whatever no I say look
if you do this this will be the
consequence and that's more like what is
taught in political science you know
political science includes a lot of
subjects including murder I guess you
know of
assassinations um it's not really part
of political science but you know it's
not a branch of political science but it
is part of politics right so even that's
acceptable or in in the political world
and you have to get used to it yeah
there are assassinations and that might
even happen to this gentleman M he may
not make it to the end of his term okay
okay and I'll withhold my opinion on
that anyways the point here is that you
know I don't look at it this is what we
should do and this what the uh uh
politicians should do no if they do this
this is going to be the consequence
that's the way I look at it and uh yeah
every policy that you implement
depending on the country has its results
and you have to live with those results
and a good way of looking at what
results we've had is looking at the
history and saying you know what was
done in the past and what outcomes did
we get out of those policies and that's
where you should look at Politics As far
as I'm concerned other than that uh I
put it in the context of Extinction and
I'm saying all these people no matter
what they do is irrelevant all of them I
don't care what the Chinese do what the
Russians do what the every country in
Africa does every country in South
America it doesn't matter because we're
all due for extinction
and uh it's inevitable and none of this
and none of these politicians will be
able to change that course okay so uh
that's why I don't pay attention to
politics anymore another reason okay
another person asked a similar question
he says you spoken about your fa falling
out with socialism a lot of people argue
whether or not Marxism could work as a
political system the truth is any
political or economic system can work as
long as it works on paper right we can
make anything work for that matter but
you know we're humans and we have 8
billion uh Minds out there each one
pulling their card in their own
Direction you know it's very hard to put
that all together there is nothing wrong
with anarchism or democracy or a 1984
State people can organize Societies in
all sorts of ways and those systems can
last for hundreds of years ahuh the key
is the content of the system in other
words the people right the people can be
eron faith
industrious or hopeless they make or
break the system because living things
especially humans are unpredictable yeah
meaning we all have our ways of thinking
and therefore you know you can't say
that this policy is going to produce
this effect necessarity there's a
tendency to produce certain effects but
not precisely the one you want okay
that's the point and this tells us that
the culture and more importantly
genetics is the determining factor in
the success of a political or econ
economic system uh I'm not going to say
that genetics um uh really has a bearing
uh you know you take the uh American
Indians you know they were displaced by
the US Army in the late uh 19th century
uh killed a lot of Indians and
essentially you were fighting you know
you had Indians who were in The Hunter
Gathering stage they were still shooting
arrows at Buffalo you know and they were
competing against people who were much
better armed right better
organized uh more population also Etc
and so you know the the white man he
displaced the red man that's what
actually happened and um and you know
you have people like an Rand Ein Rand
you know she says well they deserved it
because they were weak I wouldn't take
it that far but what is a reality is
that you know someone who is superior
in development will usually conquer
someone who is less developed and
enslave them or you know uh compel them
to pay tribute you know which is about
the same thing uh so this does happen
yeah it's happened throughout history
and it's not the fault of the Indians I
wouldn't say they deserved it but it's
what happened okay and uh there was not
much they could do about it they were
displaced out of their land pushed out
and the white man took
over and This Land is Our Land now it's
not your land anymore that's the way it
worked and there's not and that's all
you can say about politics you know it's
it's just the law of the strongest okay
in the end that's what it is and only
when two strong or equally strong uh
groups meet that's when they decide to
sign a treaty of some kind otherwise you
know the strong will always overcome the
week and so um you know and again uh I
don't see this in the context of
Extinction I don't think it really
matters uh we're due for extinction
there's nothing we can do about it why
because the whole system is going to
collapse uh economic system it's going
to collapse it's going to collapse
partly due to Wars you know we're now
getting into all these wars we can say
we've started World War III in the sense
that you know the whole world is up in
arms in many parts of the world at least
there there's a lot of activity right
and uh it might stop few months down the
road or it could get worse and if it
gets worse uh you can say that you know
now you're seeing the beginning of World
War I what is different about World War
II than uh from World War II or World
War I is that we're in the service
economy and so manufacturing is not
going to put people back to work like it
did you know in World War II for example
that's not going to happen and so war is
now uh not it doesn't favor doesn't
favor um getting more jobs you know
expanding Etc war is now going to be
destructive only there will be nothing
getting us out of War other than you
know treaties and uh having peace with
our neighbor and uh that's another
reason which I don't for which I don't
get involved into politics anymore is
that you know when I was in my 20s you
know I knew everything about politics
you couldn't convince me of
anything uh I was an expert in politics
and uh and that is you know you wanted
this Ideal World you wanted the
Brotherhood of Man you know uh Love Thy
Neighbor you know peace on Earth Good
Will to man it never happened at least
in my life and I don't think it'll ever
happen it's a it's a great ideal but
Mother Nature has other plans and the
nature the what Mother Nature has as far
as I'm concerned is uh competition you
need to fight they want people to fight
uh you know the lion doesn't reach an
agreement with the other lion said look
look let's not fight guys why don't we
just you know share our Harens with each
other you get to sleep with her and I
get to sleep with the other one over
there no no it doesn't weren't that way
you got to fight you're forced to fight
Mother Nature wants you to fight you
know and uh T-Rexes must have had the
same situation I would take it all the
way to the Cambrian right there's always
been competition and fighting when that
stops it's because the animals don't
exist anymore they're not around they
disappeared they became extinct so the
way I look at all this is very simple
you know and that is that um let me turn
this off here here for a second here uh
that is that you know uh competition is
is how Mother Nature likes she
wants uh within the species and between
species to for there to be fighting
there's got to be a struggle you know
and and this uh socialism you could say
where we're all Brothers we agree to lay
down our weapons and work together uh
you know like in uh some of these um
call them koses in Russian or and kibuts
in in Israel you know all these um
agricultural compounds where they all
get together these cooperatives and so
on and that's not the way it works for
the whole world you know you can't run
the world like that and that's what I
used to believe in I don't believe in
that
anymore and or and fought for and so on
won't do it anymore I I learned my
lesson okay uh one PA says the following
this one struck a chord with me it says
dinosaurs didn't go extinct oh my God I
didn't know that okay it's just false to
think that modern biological
classification doesn't assert fairly
strongly that birds are dinosaurs uhuh
it's a
consensus the way biology classifies
species and groups of species is in
terms of evolutionary descent and
there's just no account of what the uh
group dinosaur is that would include for
example T-Rex and
stegosaurs and not include Eagles and
crows and ravens in other words he says
the the term dinosaur has not been very
precisely defined it's kind of broadly
defined and includes the birds so he
says dinosaurs didn't go extinct because
the birds are still around that's what
not only him but lots of people out
there say this uh
no no once again no no no way so what's
the problem with this well we got to go
kind of slowly here
okay you look at Birds you know and uh
did are they dinosaurs well let's find
out because this fell says that's what
uh the biologist paleontologists this
they all agreed they have this consensus
that birds are dinosaurs okay dinosaurs
if you recall Jurassic and Cretaceous
right and before the Jurassic there was
a known as the Triassic and the kings of
the Triassic were the archosaurs okay
and so you look it up and you find out
this arasar is a clay of
diapsid
cupid tetrapods with birds and
crocodilians being the only living
representative Birds I thought they were
dinosaurs now it turns out that the
birds are
archosaurs uh they're like you know
those crocodiles there because that's
what archosaurs were primarily you know
they were these
um uh crocodiles that walked on either
two legs or four legs you know so they
were more like land animals I guess uh
but this is what U was these were the
riging species throughout the uh
Trias and now this person says that
everybody's agreed that the birds really
are dinosaurs and here it says they were
not dinosaurs they were
archosaurs or at least that they were
not they're not saying that they were
not dinosaurs but that they're
archosaurs archosaurs are distinct from
dinosaurs so are birds dinosaurs or are
they archosaurs and you can see there it
says you know the whole thing same thing
that um arasar includes crocodilians and
extinct relatives includes
Birds okay so it's confirmed birds are
archosaurs or Des from them so what's
the problem here uh I mean can we really
say that
um that um dinosaurs never went extinct
because the birds are still around and
they are part of uh the dinosaurs well
we can just as well say the archosaurs
never went extinct because the birds are
still around in fact Al go even F and
say that the synapses you know the uh
mammal likee reptiles of the peran they
never went extinct because the birds are
still around and um you know the
amphibians of the Carboniferous they
would go extinct because the birds are
still around and I guess I can take that
all the way to Cambrian so what's the
problem here well the problem here is
when people use things out of context
words out of context because they never
Define them in the proper context okay
when when they talk about claves in a in
a given U context se you can say that
you know Birds uh came from a similar
line or branched off from the dinosaur
sometime in the past that's different
than saying talking about Extinction
okay when we talk about Extinction we
know what an arasur is and we don't say
oh the birds are the archosaurs are
still around because the birds are still
flying around no we don't say that
because the archosaur in the context of
Extinction in the context of Extinction
refers to those animals that died at the
end of the Trias there are no archosaurs
today I don't care if birds are
archosaurs or not there are no
archosaurs in the context of Extinction
and when we talk about the extinction of
the dinosaurs we're talking about the
same thing we're saying that those
dinosaurs that we call dinosaurs that
everybody relates to and uh normally
Associates with the word dinosaurs those
died at the end of the Cretaceous okay
they're not around anymore what what we
have around today is a branch that
branched off early and we don't call
them D we don't call a bird a dinosaur
okay and so yeah because if we do then
uh we have this situation you know you
got to watch out in New York City of one
of these uh T-Rexes are still flying
around you look at the sky you know call
911 if if you see something like this no
no the birds are still around because
they're not dinosaurs in the context of
the word
extinction in the context of the word
extinction you're talking about two
different things when you say that the
dinosaurs are still alive today because
the birds are alive that's an irrational
statement okay because you're confusing
the context that's the problem there
okay here
um I mean can we say that the synapses
are still around you know the
pelicar of the peran or the therapsid of
the lake peran you know here here you
let me show you a picture here of these
okay these are synapsis say one of two
major claves of vertebrae animals in the
group amata okay the other being the
sasds okay so uh which includes the
reptiles and birds okay so the first
ones the synapses you know they include
us you know they include the mammals
okay we descend from them we did not
descend from the ssids or the reptiles
or the Birds we descended from the
synapsis okay so there you have two
examples uh the first the one on the
left is um uh dimetrodon and the one on
the right is uh gor gorgonops okay uh
first one is the one on the left is more
from the ER peran the second one is from
the late peran uh do any of those look
like your
mother okay if they do well then maybe
the synapses are still around you know
but if uh if your mother looks a little
different than them then maybe you know
the synapses are no longer around
because we descend from the synapses as
well so it's irrational to say that the
synapsis never became extinct because we
humans are still alive and we descend
from them you know how far you're going
to take this again it means that you're
not understanding the context when you
say something dumb like that like saying
you know the the birds are still around
and so the dinosaurs didn't die no
that's the wrong Contex okay the
dinosaurs died 65 million years ago no
dinosaur survived what we call a
dinosaur and in the context of
Extinction that's what we call a
dinosaur you cannot say that that the
dinosaurs are still living and flying
around New York City because you know we
still have Birds which are dinosaurs no
birds are not dinosaurs for that
purposes for the purposes of Extinction
that's the context please do not confuse
it okay don't make a rational state M
like saying you know the dinosaurs are
still around because the birds are
flying that's that this comes out of
paleontologists who are not really
paleontologist what they are is Stam
collectors you know they people think a
a paleontologist is a guy who goes in
there like you know Indiana Jones you
know he goes with a gun and with a whip
is that are those the tools of a you
know of a paleontologist a gun and a
whip oh yeah sometimes he takes a pick
and a hammer also do he go he goes in
there and he you know breaks up the rock
pulls out a bone assembles it puts it in
a uh in a museum and starts collecting
money now that's not a paleontologist
that is a stamp collector paleontologist
is one thing and one thing only it's a
person who can explain extinction
because it's part of Science and science
is only about explaining rationally so
we need a rational explanation for
extinction that's what a paleontologist
does and we don't have any
paleontologists on Earth because all
paleontologists have irrational uh
explanations for how animals in the past
died they don't have an explanation for
mass extinction or for background
Extinction you know when a single
species dies all background extinctions
man did them all we killed them all
that's that's the answer they'll give
you it's an irrational explanation and
then a mechanism and then uh how did the
mass extinctions occur in the past well
they have no clue they always come up
with all these catastrophes it's only
catastrophes that they put forth oh
there was a climate change oh there was
a disease oh there was a an asteroid
that hit the earth or maybe a supernova
that blew up up there somewhere in in
the skies no no none of those can
explain the only thing
a a an Extinction Theory a theory of
Extinction has to explain and that is
selectivity if you cannot explain
selectivity you do not have a theory of
Extinction because that's the only thing
you have to explain how does Mother
Nature choose a clay or an order or
whatever a group of animals and leave
the ones next to them alive and when
they have to go in you know and do ad
hoc stuff like you know for every
species you got to make an exception say
well this one this one H was hit by
sulfuric acid and the other one it was
acid rain and no when you have to you
know make an exception for every species
it's because you don't have a theory
Mother Nature doesn't have different
Theory 100 different mechanisms for
producing Extinction okay she only has
one for mass extinction and one for
background okay there are no billions of
theories for how animals disappear okay
and hopefully they're all natural Mother
Nature is
natural okay uh so here we have uh one
Extinction that happened it's called the
old sin Extinction happened somewhere
around the mid peran okay and I like
what they say here says possible causes
this is out of the Wikipedia in the
peer-reviewed encyclopedia people
sometimes say oh but encyclop the
Wikipedia anybody can post there not so
it's peer reviewed you try to change
some of the especially the scientific
articles and you'll find a whole bunch
of people who PE review what you just
said they won't allow you to put
anything you want in there so yeah you
can say it's peer reviewed especially
when it's run by or monitored by a lot
of so-called scientists out there that
have their ideas from College from
University and they will not allow you
to put just anything in the Wikipedia so
don't tell me it's not peer reviewed it
is uh unofficially but it is it's
censored okay uh anyways Olson's mass
extinction out of the Wikipedia possible
causes there is no widely accepted
theory for the cause of Olsen's
Extinction no kidding you know have a
theory for any of the extinctions for
that matter Recent research has
indicated that climate change may be a
possible cause climate change cannot
cause an exch Extinction never caused an
Extinction on the face of the Earth in
the history of life on Earth extreme
environments were observed from the
peran of Kansas which resulted from a
combination of hot climate and acidic
Waters and that's all they can produce
these nonsense theories you know they
cannot explain with this how animals die
they don't die because the climate
changed over thousands of years doesn't
work that way okay and here you can see
what happened this is Olsen's Extinction
right there around the center of the uh
peran somewhere in the middle okay and
you can see there was a difference in
the types of
synapses uh you got the age of picars
the ones on the left that look more like
reptiles you got the other ones the
therapsids and they look more more like
you know Lions you could say you know or
hippopotamuses or whatever okay so you
can see they're they're kind of
different uh but what's the issue here
the issue is that you say well why are
these animals not CL officially the cpds
right why aren they classified as
mammals they look pretty much like
mammals to me and the reason they're not
mammals is these are lions that laid
eggs these are w s that laid eggs or or
bears that laid eggs okay these animals
laid eggs that's why they have some
characteristics of mammals and some
characteristics of reptiles you know I
mean we're talking about way back when
and so yeah the we can't say that the
therapsids or the synapsids or or the
mamalik reptiles in general are still
around because we are still alive that's
not rational and here's another uh take
this is the uh dinosaurs group okay they
really started around the Triassic there
you can see some of the types of uh
dinosaurs they found in those days we
have very few samples from the Triassic
really from the middle Triassic onwards
and then really they bloomed in the
Jurassic and you say well why did they
bloom well a good reason that they bloom
is in the Trias at the end of the
Triassic at the border which the
Jurassic the uh Dums uh type of seed
Fern died out and it's not just one
plant it was a a family or order of
plants called Dums and they were all
over the planet so uh the point here is
that if
um what is it an archosaur wanted to
live wanted to survive he had to eat
that because that was pretty much the
only food that was around that was the
issue okay and so here we have uh the
Dums disappear and guess what the
archosaurs Disappeared except for the
birds
right and then we have the Jurassic you
had these long necks Jurassic was
specifically an age of the long necks
not not exclusively but it's
characterized by dinosaurs who had long
necks when you get to the Cretaceous you
can see what's happening there's a
transition there and you get another
type of um dinosaur more or less like
what I just showed for the
uh you know the synapsis of the peran
you know what changed was the morphology
of these animals there are different
types of animals the first ones like to
eat you know the uh from the high trees
because they had long necks
obviously um they had some uh they were
eating from top of the trees in other
words whereas the ones that come in the
Cretaceous they more closer to the
ground okay it's good that you read the
dinosaur heresies of Robert Baker and he
does a good job of explaining all that
stuff in quite a bit of detail all I can
tell you is that um you cannot say that
that the dinosaurs are still around
because we still have Birds that's the
wrong context for the word bird you
cannot associate the word bird and
dinosaur together with a word extinction
we're talking about two different things
okay whether Birds descended or or were
line parallel to the dinosaurs that
branched out at some point irrelevant to
the question at hand the question at
hand is the word dinosaur fits in the
context of
Extinction those all died no dinosaur
survived past 65 or there about 65
million years ago okay so you can't say
the dinosaurs are still flying around
New York
City but some people believe this you
know that's what they repeat without
understanding the
context okay let's get on with the uh
ether we had ether and we also had black
hole so I'm going to cover both of them
we had a couple questions on The Ether
let's see what these people have to say
about The Ether here it is one fell say
the following I think here says what an
ether is composed of it must be composed
of some form of objects ahuh so he's
already talking about it's what is
comprised of not what it is that's the
first thing we need to point out there
first sentence first sentence right up
front right however most types of
objects are already associated with
other theories for example particle with
the standard model and these objects
would be completely unique well uh not
really because uh you know the particle
that Quantum uses is not really a
particle it's a number okay and they
call it a particle it's a number with a
unit that's what quantum
visualizes or understands when someone
says particle it's not a cord puzzle
it's not a ball so Quantum doesn't have
uh a particle hypothesis meaning a a
particle a COR cor pusle Theory okay
it's completely a mathematical con
construct okay these bits are are the
smaller scale objects tiny bits of a
larger ether medium they are not made of
smaller objects ahuh so have uh these
little bits and I don't know what he's
going to call them he's going to call
them bits okay the shape of each bit is
generally spherical so far it looks like
he's talking about a particle I mean he
could have fooled me they are all the
same size okay they would not be
deformable wouldn't be able to change
its shape okay again we're talking about
a little ball that doesn't change its
shape sounds very much like what the
ether has always been a bunch of
particles tiny little particles you know
little balls
that's what everybody always conceived
of You Know The Ether being couldn't
gain or lose mass and eternal object
okay position relative to other bits
could change in other words we have
distance okay changing between these
little particles meaning they're
vibrating or moving around right uh the
objects themselves couldn't change
energy transfers would be simple direct
transfers of momentum as one bit ran
into neighboring bit in other words they
don't deform right bits couldn't absorb
any momentum change or shap turnning an
impact okay 100% of that momentum would
result in a redirection of the bids
involved not sure how to go from ether
to your electromagnetic ropes though
maybe your electromagnetic ropes would
be some additional phenomenon itself
composed of these material
patterns okay I was going to answer the
fell but uh someone beat me to
it so let's put his his reply very short
down to the point he says you wrote
nothing of substance literally in all
that wall of text and yeah he's totally
right because what this fell is saying
he's saying uh what The Ether has always
been and there you see it bunch of
particles vibrating particles changing
their distance with respect to each
other all the dots are the same size
they're
undeformable um what else can I say
they're round we always imagin them
round nobody imagines them cubic or
whatever so we have to think of this as
round little balls right tiny ones and
well everybody has to who proposes The
Ether has to also identify as the black
stuff that gives shape to each particle
or contrast to each particle Nobody Does
that they say oh The Ether yeah but
ether what's what's behind ether I mean
is ether the same thing as space or is
space backdrop to each particle that you
know giving shape to each particle of
ether right but that's what the ether
has always been and uh so what is
different from what we propose here here
you see it okay we have rest of the
world has always proposed bunch of
particles since the days of the Greek
everybody assumes that what's out there
is a bunch of particles that they can't
see maybe we can touch them somehow I
don't know but we can't see them and so
they say well there's these particles
out there okay and so how many are there
well it's infinite it extends to Nowhere
or it's growing I don't know I don't
know what infinite means okay there's no
such thing as an infinite object in
physics what do we say we say that all
atoms in the universe are interconnected
they're bound to each other okay so we
have that and so that's different from
what everybody else does this is the
only site on the planet that says that
all atoms are physically interconnected
you have the Buddhists you have the
Hindus they talk about connections
through energy and you know all this
other stuff no no no you cannot connect
with Concepts okay we connect with a
physical object we're saying two atoms
are connected by a physical object that
has the shape of a rope or DNA like uh
entity two pair of twine threads you
know okay another follow gives us an
idea what the ether is the ether is not
a thing aha subject or material good I'm
glad all these people Begin by saying
what it's not they never tell you what
it is it e you what it
ain't okay The Ether is the zero point
uhuh zero point on a grid translation
from that grid is radiation which
defines all existence of matter or
phenomena it's a principle of rest
versus disturbance whatever that means
uh okay so there you have the zero point
that's what it looks like zero
point looks like
nothing so yeah The Ether looks like
nothing folks I according to this all so
yeah once again I always say that eist
is a person who has no idea what the
ether is okay that's why he believes in
The Ether that's why he proposes The
Ether okay and so what can I say all
these people are uh off on a tangent
they're going out into left field they
don't even know what they're talking
about because they never defined what
the ether is okay here we have
um a followup on that which is
what is a black hole and I put a video
out there and some people uh replied or
put comments on that so let's look at
those and it's really related to this
ether the fact that people don't Define
things they don't think definitions are
important they dismiss that as semantics
or word salad or word Wizardry and they
say ah you're raising semantic arguments
well science is 150% semantics you know
you got to give someone a theory that
that uh the person understands in the
case of physics a mechanism a cause and
if you cannot Define your terms or you
have not defined your terms and you use
the your terms
inconsistently then you have an
irrational Theory okay so you have to
define the terms you know what is called
semantics you got to do semantics and
therefore we can understand you
otherwise you don't we don't understand
you you think you gave your theory
properly we're going to be talking about
that a little bit today uh but what
people he out there is something else
okay because you have not defined your
terms and people understand different
things from different terms unless the
key words in your dissertation are
properly defined okay okay so here we
have this fellow says he's a physicist
comes over and says the following says I
don't know how to put it nicely I don't
need for people to put anything nicely
here you can cuss my mother for all I
care you know but as an ex physicist I
feel that the video creator has not
enough experience in physics or science
in order to debate about
epistemology okay so I got a rotten egg
in my face maybe a foot a boot in my
face okay so what did this great
physicist this great scientists say
first thing he says is I do not see why
the word object would need a rigorous
definition and that says it all that
says it all for me I mean here you have
I mean assuming he is a physicist I will
concede the the claim I don't know it's
true but we'll we'll concede it right if
he is a physicist he would be the
typical physicist uh in other words a
mathematical physic nothing related to
physics at all it's just math okay what
these people never found out that you
can't do physics without an object you
need an object to do physics if you wipe
every object in the universe out of you
know you could make them
disappear uh what would be happening
what what are you measuring what are you
what are you watching what's happening
you know there's nothing occurring and
so when these people say you know that
uh you know why do need to define the
word object it means they never went to
kindergarten physics and it applies not
only to this well but it applies to all
so called mathematical physicists
meaning mathemagicians they do
everything with magic why because
they're always moving Concepts around
they're moving the field vibrating the
field or exciting the field they're
waving the wave they're moving the mass
they're transferring the energy or even
worse carrying the force or transferring
what information you know what what kind
of physics is that that's nonsense
that's poy no if you're going to use the
word transfer you better transfer an
object you can transfer a baby you can
transfer a rock you can transfer I don't
know a lion if you want but you can't
transfer you know energy it's impossible
to transfer energy because it's very
hard to get a hold of that all that
energy you know with your hand touching
it you know if you want to have one
meaning uh definition for object why not
create a definition which includes
something reasonably well described by
The swar Shield or Cur Solutions meaning
a black hole well it's the other way
around here the guy who's proposing the
black hole we clean our nose holes with
black holes okay so uh there's no such
thing as a black hole that's what that's
what the point here is the point is that
we Define the word object once we Define
it in a way we can use it
consistently guess what you know re it
it eliminates all black holes worm holes
Dark Matter Big Bang the whole work and
particles so-called particles of quantum
mechanics all that gets washed down the
drain because none of them qualify as
objects as things you cannot say you're
going to move a Quantum particle because
a Quantum particle ain't the particle
Quantum particle is not a COR pusle
Quantum particle is something totally
different you know what they accelerate
along the beam line at the
accelerators these nuclear accelerators
uh that ain't a particle it's a number
usually in measured in terms of energy I
know because I ran you know
accelerators and all I can tell you is
yeah we were told that we accelerated
ion in fact they were called ion
accelerators okay and I implanters and
what it is you know they say look you
know you're you're accelerating an ion
you're accelerating an electron or
you're accelerating whatever and you say
well what is an electron is it a
particle no electron is a charge 1.6 *
10us 19 kums that's what a electron is
that's what a mathematician sees that's
what he understands he don't tell him
about little balls he doesn't understand
that stuff he doesn't deal with that
stuff he just says that's a charge
that's so many charges that went down
the beam line that's the way they look
at it so yeah this how doesn't know why
we have to define the word object then
he said why don't you define it in such
a way that you include black holes
because we
can't you can't you can't Define it in
such a way you include black holes
because then you would be using the term
inconsistently that's why you
can't in fact here's here's a better one
for you you better hold you better get a
beer at this point okay there's such a
thing called an unparticle we have the
particle and we have the unparticle okay
here it is the unparticle Wikipedia
again the peer reviewed encyclopedia a
form of matter that cannot be explained
in terms of particles because its
components are scale invariant uhuh
electrons for example always have the
same mass regardless of their energy or
momentum but this is not always the case
massless particles such as photons can
exist with their properties scaled
equally okay this this immunity to uh to
scaling is called scale
invariance so now you know what an
unparticle is we have the particles
which ain't particles and then you have
the unparticles which I guess ain't
particles
either yeah they come up with all this
nonsense because uh mathematical
physicist don't work with things with
objects they never knew they had to
define the word object the word thing
and turns out you can't do physics
without a thing meaning that the first
word you have to Define in physics is
the word thing what is a thing and they
never did in the life 10,000 years this
is the first site that defines the word
thing what is a thing what is
a something a an object a body you know
substance okay someone says bills
requirements of an object based reality
aren't for
everyone well they had better be let me
tell you this they had better be for
everyone because if you don't put an
object in there in that invisible area
intangible area between two m magnets or
between the Earth and the Sun if you
don't put an object there then you're
doing black magic you're you're not even
doing religion religion is just
Supernatural uh this uh using uh action
out of distance that's uh
irrational that's not because at least
put an angel in there you know you want
to put an angel you want to put God you
want to put a spirit ghost no problem
put something in there and say look let
me show you how I think action at a
distance is done and you put God in
there and say look here's God he moves
his magic wand this is how he does it
okay we can listen to that you know but
if the guy says look you have the Earth
and the Sun and it's all done by action
at a distance nothing in
between then you're not even doing
religion you're doing irrationality
totally totally irrationality and
hopefully you don't put a concept into
such as a field or energy or you know
mass or anything like that you know
that's even worse that means we take
have to take you to the Nut House okay
another fell says black hole an object
an object a thing says a black hole is a
thing that's what he thinks it is so
heavy it's constantly crushing itself
into a smaller and smaller object and it
does this faster than light speed this
is what he was taught at the
monastery an object that is being
crushed well doesn't Crush itself all
all the way out of existence I mean are
there still atoms there left over or are
the atoms also crushed out of existence
what happened to the other I mean do we
end up with one atom or do we end up
with zero atoms nothing no
volume and the correct answer is this
second one it ends up with nothing
absolutely nothing and uh our good
friend U what was his name
subaman Chandra secar proved that that
mathematically he won the 1983 Nobel
Prize for proving listen carefully and
people say no well that's not true for
proving that a black hole collapses to
zero volume zero size no shape no
diameter no radius no nothing the
definition of absolutely nothing vacuum
okay space so yeah black hole is Zero
Dimensional and they say the singularity
singularities are mathematical terms
that means zero volume zero nothing
there's nothing there so so the star you
know crushes all matter out of existence
all atoms are crushed out of existence
there's nothing there and you end up
with a singularity which is nothing it's
the volume of nothing and how much
volume does nothing have well it has
nothing that's how much volume it has
put it in any unit you want okay so yeah
this guy just thinking that oh it just
crushes crush crush it becomes a little
ball no it doesn't stay at the little
ball it continues crushing until there's
nothing there no matter whatsoever with
no matter well then there's no Mass
meaning because that's a definition of
mass you know quantity of matter or a
measure a quantity of matter meaning we
have absolutely no
mass and so yeah black hole is the
definition of absolutely nothing not of
something which is what object
is so uh so much for that but this what
people believe they they just throw
these things around they don't even know
what they're saying
okay okay give me a second here clean up
here okay uh another father says what a
black ho is an object another one made
of neutrons and
protons I mean these people say whatever
they don't understand squat about
anything I mean it's just unbelievable
people just say nonsense about ether and
black hole they they never took the
trouble to really find out what they're
talking about they just go on and say
well because the scientists over there
in Cambridge and Harvard they told us
all this stuff and they just memorize
and regurgitate and they don't
understand nothing they don't understand
half of what they're reading okay here's
another says the hole in the center of a
jawbreaker okay you know those candies
right is a 3D form called a sphere okay
the wall of that jawbreaker has the same
shape right okay the wall you know it's
the inside of a football has ball shape
also right the wall of jawbreaker is an
object the whole Space vacuum isn't okay
good so far so well so far we're in
agreement they both have volumes that
can be calculated absolutely not forms
have volume shapes only have areas both
can be calculated yeah the problem is
that first sentence and that next the
last one yeah the whole is not a 3D form
and um and uh it doesn't have
volume okay and so let's uh let's show
that
okay in fact you can see it right there
at the bottom okay you can see uh the
jaw breaker that's you know now we're
going to make an opening there show the
hole okay so there you see the hole and
that's when you remove the jawbreaker
completely get rid of it and that's what
the hole looks like out there in space
right looks like nothing looks like very
clear like nothing okay that's what it
looks like so no what is the volume
there you know uh what is the form you
have no form and no volume there so I
don't know what he's talking about about
the hole having form and volume not at
all but if if you disagree we challenge
you to bring a hole just a hole okay not
the jawbreaker not the ball uh football
whatever you know just bring the hole to
the um conference and show us what the
volume and what the form of that hole is
what are you going to
bring okay and uh here we have uh Bugs
Bunny proving to us what I just said
okay uh hole has no form or shape hole
has no volume this becomes clear when
the object that has shape is eliminated
see the hole is a dependent you can say
object and therefore it's not an object
because if it's dependent it's a concept
okay it's a relation between two things
you're treating the hole as an object
you're treating the ball as an object
you're making a relation and you're
saying oh the hole is in relation has a
spherical shape because it has the same
shape as the inside wall of the ball uh
wrong you know when you can when you do
that you're establishing a relation we
don't do that in in science the way we
do it in science we point and say whole
what are you going to point to hole in
space you know
nothing so the hole disappeared you know
as soon as you remove the the ball right
there is no such thing as a standalone
hole okay the hole was merely an
architectural uh characteristic of that
object now you see bugs you know he here
on Earth he dug a hole in the ground we
all understand that right and if you
remove the ground that's what bugs looks
like in the same exact position out
there in outer space okay is he in a
hole there he looks like he's not looks
like he's an astronaut to
me so uh no you should not re uh confuse
the hole with the thing that gives the
inside you know it's just a
architectural thing of of the thing in
this case the ball that's what the hole
is it's part of the really the ball
you're you're confusing whether the
glass is half full or half empty and
you're saying the half empty part is a
physical object no it's not you know
know the half empty has to stand alone
you know we can take the water on the
bottom half you know or whatever you got
there put it out into space remove the
glass real quick and it'll have the
shape for a split second you can take a
snapshot and you'll have water there the
top part nothing there you know so the
hole on the top of the glass the empty
part of you know there's that's not an
object and again people confuse these
things okay uh F says draw an invisible
intangible physical electromagnetic
thread okay uh this is what the
Invisible Thread looks like um you know
normally you know it's invisible so the
you can't see it neither can the blind
man you know uh when it's visible it
looks more or less like that and I made
it visible because the word thread is
what we're trying to illustrate here
we're illustrating a thread blind man
still can't see it so see and touch have
nothing to do with it it has to do with
whether the thread has shaped
and there you have the single closed
loop thread of the Rope model the one we
propose underlies all matter it's the
you can say the elementary or
fundamental entity that makes up
everything in the universe okay and um
here let me draw something else here's
an invisible ghost okay that's what an
invisible ghost looks like you know the
one that moved my curtain uh that's what
he looks like I think it was my
great-grandmother who came and visited
me and talked to me and something like
that and there's a visible ghost uh so
you have an invisible ghost and I can
draw a visible ghost as well you know so
uh is is that little fell there good
Casper you know is is is that ghost and
object yeah because it has shape that's
what an object is so yeah a ghost is an
object okay whereas uh you know energy
is not for example you know okay uh well
says reflection is the bending of light
we talked about bending light we're
going to talk a little bit about that
today as it passes through a medium such
as water or glass gravitational lensing
is caused by the what bending bending of
space time you're going to bend time how
are you gonna what sense does it make to
say that you're going to bend time you
know how do you bend cons if you grab
them with your tweezers or with your
hands I mean I don't know the seconds
and you bend them due to the mass of the
object which affects the what the path
of light passing by well the question is
are we talking about light as particles
or are we talking about light as a stick
because if light is a stick then you can
talk about bending but if you talk
about that light is made out of
particles discrete particles then you're
talking about um deflecting or I don't
know uh you can say um that you that
they swerved they just changed course
okay because you can't bend a particle
so can't talk about the bending of light
or of of a particle if if if you're what
you're really trying to say is that it
was deflated it changed course that's
something else okay but see they don't
they're not careful about their language
so they said it uh uh you know bent the
path of light well the path did we bend
the highway or did we Bend
or did we deflect a series of photons
what did what did we do here or did we
bend the wave meaning the wave extends
all the way to Andromeda
uninterruptedly and so then you can
maybe say well if the wave is a thing
and it extends all the way to Andromeda
yeah we bent the wave you can say that
because it's an
elongated conceptually elongated object
okay it's not even an object it's a
bunch of vectors but that's a separate
issue but if you treat the wave as a
thing you can say the wave bent so you
need to know if light is photons or a
wave an extended Wave It's a discrete
particle you cannot talk about bending
light so you got to determine what light
is before you can use the word bent or
the word
path and it says the major distinction
is that in refraction the light changes
its direction at the interface between
two transparent media but otherwise
travels in a straight line travels uh
how does a wave travel I mean here you
have uh the beginning of the wave here
you have the ending of the wave and does
it travel like a little sailboat you
know how how does a wave
travel where does it begin where does it
end you knowes there more waves and more
little these more of these humps there
you
know and again talks about light passes
by Massive object and again the problem
here is the language these people don't
real that as that language is important
because otherwise we don't understand
what they're saying because we don't
know what they're referring to what do
you mean by light I mean are you talking
about discrete particles or extended
wave what is an extended wave is that a
concept or an object we need to
determine that first so that we can
follow your
presentation okay and uh so here it is
you can see it here uh there's your wave
okay beginning and end where does it
begin where does it end does it travel
like a little sailboat to Earth one at a
time or is that it is extend you know
from there to here and if it extends
uninterruptedly then you can talk about
bending if that's a physical object
which it ain't you know beginning there
but see this is the issue the issue is
that people don't want to Define these
things and what you're staring at is a
bunch of vectors magnitude and Direction
that's what the blue and the red arrows
are just uh you know uh vectors so this
is a mathematical concept that they're
moving from Andromeda all the way down
here if it's a wave okay so you cannot
even talk about the wave traveling
because it's a concept it's a
mathematical Concepts Concepts don't
travel you know love does not travel
intelligence doesn't
travel um Grace you know whatever other
concept you can think of they don't
travel distance doesn't Travel location
doesn't travel you know no concept that
I know of especially static concept you
Trav okay so let's get on with
defraction because uh what we have here
is what I just said serves as an
introduction to this and where do we go
well we start with these two fellows and
these are the new breeds of mathematical
physicist physicist word is too big for
them they're just mathemati they know
nothing at all about physics they cannot
explain a single phenomenon which is
invisible or intangible or mediated by
invisible and tangible entities okay
that's the problem these are the new
breeds of mathem magician one is man OD
Dow he runs one program Derek Miller he
runs another one okay they make lots of
money I guess right they're sponsored by
uh big companies and what do these guys
teach well they they just regurgitate
the party line so you're not going to
learn anything from them other than
nonsense this is all they talk about
just pure nonsense quantum mechanics and
general relativity primarily a little
bit of strength Theory right and those
are all irrational theories because
they're they are all in the uh business
of moving Concepts and you know that's
why we need to determine what is physics
what is science is uh physics math just
equations and predictions and
observations and uh winning prizes and
doing the talk circuit is that is that
what physics is about or is physics
about give me an explanation How the
Universe works okay so that's that's the
bottom line and these people don't tell
you ever how the Universe Works meaning
why it works the way it does the how is
always very confusing because people
confuse the how with a why you ask um
how does the universe work and they give
you an equation and I said that's not
what I wanted to hear I wanted to know
you know why the cause the mechanism
that brings this spoon downwards that's
what I want to know that's what I want
to understand and you'll never get an
answer to that okay so good
luck um okay so here we have um give me
a second here uh this is where we start
uh one of these fellas uh he I think
it's Derek Miller he says um in one of
his video he says a Dutch bi Dutch
physicist named Huggins proposed that
light was a wave well first of all I
want to clarify that uh hins Christian
henss wasn't the one who proposed The
Wave for the first time he published his
book in
1690 25 years after
um Robert Hook you know he he wrote his
micrographia uh in 1665 20 years earlier
that's where the notion that light is a
wave started okay as far as I know
that's as far as I could trace it I
don't know if there was was anyone on
Earth other than Robert Hook that came
up with that uh I have to also believe
that it was um Robert Hook because uh
he's the first guy who used the
microscope to study light and he saw
these
wavy fringes and that's where he thought
that maybe light was some kind of wave
that's why he proposed for the first
time that light is a wave and then hins
uh many years later you know sided with
Robert Hook against Newton Newton
continued to Believe In The Ether in
that you know that light was a bunch of
particles H the only problem there was
that whereas some some of them said you
know yeah we believe in The Ether too
but the ether waves up and down and uh
Newton just believed that the ether or
whatever light was was traveling
straight he said there there's no way
travels up and down in oscillating
manner it travels in a straight line and
so the question was which one was right
and so there was a debate for many years
and it says this debate whether light
was mediated by particles as Newton
proposed or by waves as hens propos
suggested was settled by Thomas Young's
double slit experiment and um yeah turns
out that Thomas Young you know created
this defraction defraction and what was
that well defraction was that you know
uh you produce fringes on the wall
despite that you had two slits you would
think that light passing through two
slits would produce just two slits on
the wall instead of produce the series
of fringes and that was surprising
because they couldn't explain it and
young explained it saying hey this
confirms the wave nature of light
because what you have is interference
there and you know constructive and
destructive interference that's
essentially was his um his answer but uh
what's important here is that it's uh
Thomas Young Who who told who wrote
right he wrote this that uh Newton had
done an experiment in fact it's his
third uh experiment that Thomas Young
did the third one is with a human hair
he took a hair and he ran light through
the hair and he produced the fringes
also so he did not need the slits he
wanted something very thin he found a
hair he says Newton had already done
that
experiment somehow and apparently Newton
didn't see the fringes you know I don't
even know how Thomas Young did it but he
said he could he measured the fringes uh
using a hair as well okay so just keep
in mind that um you know that that's
that's how things progressed and we're
talking about 1802 1803 that's when um
Thomas Young uh came up with uh the uh
defraction defraction um so what's the
issue the issue is that uh you know that
wasn't that didn't resolve the debate
because in 1900 you have
um max plank he comes up with a Quantum
and five years later you know uh
Einstein wrote his uh four papers and
his mirab and what happened after that
was that you know people started
thinking that light was indeed a bunch
of particles so to this day we have this
particle wave particle duality you know
it's a wave packet whatever that is and
what they mean by that really is that it
has properties of both the wave and the
particle okay but actually it's neither
neither wave nor particle so that's
where that's where we draw the line we
separate ourselves here in this site
from all the nonsense coming out of
mathematical physics which is is based
on this unimaginable entity known as the
wave particle or particle wave or uh
wave packet or Duality as they call it
you know uh no we can't do physics with
dualities first you need to identify
what the mediator of light is then you
can do all the physics you want you
don't do it in reverse and say well let
me do let me measure let me tell you how
fast and how long and no we don't care
about any of that okay in science you
first point to the object and then you
can do whatever you want with it then
you can explain a mechanism and you
don't go in reverse and say well I
measured something there and I think
it's and I I simulate it with particles
or I simulate it with waves not the way
it works
okay especially when Nei one you know
because if you're going to stay with a
wave stay with a wave no problem and if
you're going to do particles do
particles but don't mix them and say
well here this portion I'm going to
explain playing with a wave okay that's
not the way it
works okay so uh here's one site that
teaches physics okay and they Define the
hens principle so that we understand
what it is and there's a summary at the
top uh every point on a wavefront is in
itself the source of spherical wavelets
which spread out in the forward
Direction at the speed of light the sum
of these spherical wavelets forms the
wavefront in other words you have this
wavefront and each point on that
wavefront becomes the source of the next
wave front Okay that's essentially what
hgen said but uh very clearly we see
what the next sentence is it says this
Theory did not
explain exactly this Theory did not
explain why okay refraction occurred in
the first place or defraction for that
matter okay um you know these are not
theories they're not explanations what
it is is simply a description which
people call explanations erroneously
call
explanations okay and here you have hyan
St stated that light is a wave
propagating through space like ripples
in water or sound in air absolutely not
but that's how hens and everybody else
to this day visualizes it like a water
waves and that's how they explain it you
have all these water wave theorists out
there hence light spreads out like a
wave in all directions from Source yeah
they do it does and that's why you
should not talk about light in general
when you're doing that you should talk
about which Medi what is the mediator of
light what does it look like and then we
can tell you why it spreads out like
that okay the locus of points that
travel some distance during a fixed time
interval is called a wavefront thus from
a point source of light the locus of
points that light has traveled during a
fixed time period is a sphere here a
circle if you consider a 2d source so
what is the problem with this the
problem is that they're they can't see
what light is they just say from any
point source you have light going you
know uh radially in every
direction but for that you need to
identify what light is tell me what
light is I mean if it's a porcupine you
know with it's or better yet um what is
it
um the word escaped my mind uh
if you have a rolled up porcupine with
all his pins sticking outwards you know
like a star well if light travels along
each one of those points right those
pins that are sticking out well then
yeah you can't say that uh that because
light travels uh radially that because
of that you know that light is a wave or
a part okay what it is is that you have
some other thing there that's stretching
out stretching out you know extending
from that porcupine you know it's
extending out and light travels
simultaneously through all those you
know radially through all those things
okay those extended things that uh
extend from this uh star so you know you
got to look at what light is before you
can make any determination you cannot
talk about light unless you know what
light is and then all these people start
talking and they some use particles
others use waves others use both or
whenever they say well this phenomen I'm
going to you know simulate with light
with particles the this one with waves
that's not the way it works you can't
keep changing your your hypothesis your
assumptions okay so um I go into quora
okay site that answers all kinds of
questions that you always ever wanted to
know okay and um the these are the
explanations I got from mathematical
physicist and other enthusiasts on these
questions why why mechanism cause right
does light deflect at the edge at the
edges of an object do you want to know
why this is not a how question like you
know I'm going to describe what happens
no we want an explanation we want a
cause we want a mechanism and the next
question was what exactly is defraction
and how is it cause in this case the how
means why they want to know cause
mechanism again okay and the first
question we got for them is are these
questions of physics because if these
are not questions of physics we're
wasting our time you know we're saying
we're trying to answer questions which
don't belong to physics who knows what
they belong to you know mathematicians
say they belong to philosophy okay right
philosophy of science philosophy of
physic are these questions of physics if
someone asks you you know why does this
uh fall to the ground is that a question
of physics the cause what caused that to
happen the mechanism how Mother Nature
does this magic trick is that is that a
u valid question of physics so that's
the first question you really have to
answer because nobody can answer that
question in other words the
mathematicians just shove it aside and
say well that's not in that's not our uh
in our job description it's not in our
line of work but then they come in and
they try to answer those questions
because all these questions are being
answered by so-called physicists
mathematical physicist why do they come
and answer these questions if they say
it's not part of their job
descriptions I mean you know this is
where the problem is it starts okay so
here are some of the answers that these
people gave out there you know uh in
this uh for these two questions again
these are a bunch of business
enthusiasts people who studied at the
University it's a mixture of people but
you can see they all answer the same
thing says one fell says imagine every
point on a plane wave as a source of
spherical waves called hyen Source okay
draw these spherical waves and then draw
a common tangent this common tangent
represents the new shape of the wave
okay so he's just describing
illustrating right this common tangent
okay uh on on a plain wave there are
infinite hyen sources and these give
rise to infinitely many secondary
spherical waves thus the new tangent
would look again uh would look again
plain okay however once it hits a slit
here's the
explanation drum be right only a few
hugen sources survive the ones in
between the slit and these give rise to
a new wavefront which it will now be
curved that's not an explanation that's
just telling me what I just saw it's
like you know you go to the watch the
Magician on
stage and you ask the the mathematician
next to you what just happened oh very
easy I'll explain it to you I'll tell
you how and what did he said well you
know the saw moved a 10 KMS per hour you
know the guy went five Strokes cut the
lady in two
parts windows the curtains closed
curtains open the lady came up and one
piece yeah that's not a why that's not a
how did it happen that's just what
happened and that's what mathematicians
call science just you know describing
what they just saw no we want to know
how the trick is done that's what that's
where you have to use your brain you
know just to tell me what you saw I
don't need the mathematicians for that
okay so here we have another file and he
says when the Rays of light hit an edge
the atoms on the edges absorb and Reit
the light wave in the form of a
cylindrical wavefront so far description
he just says it bounces okay technically
this is called Extinction shift effect
it states that a wave of light
interacting with any interfering medium
is immediately extinguished and replaced
by a new wave again the scription he's
just saying it is so that's all you said
so far the Slate always bends around
corners to some extent just like sound
or ocean waves that was his explanation
for the Slate experiment why why the
cause the mechanism of how light curves
around a corner that's it he just stated
that it does okay great here's another
fellow he says light deflects at the
edge of an object because because he's
going to give us a why right an
explanation the edges act as barriers
that interfere with the path of light
wave causing it to bend and spread out
he hasn't told us why he just said they
do it bends it bends around corners why
well because it bends around corners
that's the why that's the cause that's
the explanation this effect is similar
to the way water uh waves defract when
they encounter the edges of an obstacle
now he's just using an analogy saying
water does the same thing but he's not
explaining why the water does that
neither hyans for that matter they or
any of these people you know to this day
no one can tell you why water does that
you know that First Source to Second
Source why every point on a first wave
front gives origin to the waves on the
second front Okay no one tell you why
that is the case just say it is so we've
observed it it happens etc
etc okay it says the amount of
defraction depends on the size of the
object in the wave the light wave we
don't care about that at all okay but
these are the explanations that you get
here's a couple more
okay Paul says this can be explained he
uses the word explained okay so he's
going to explain something here by the
hugan Fresno freno principle the central
idea is that each point along the wave
front of a wave acts as a discrete
source of spherical waves so for it's a
description he just says it is so so
each of the these conceptual Point
sources moreover oscillates at the
frequency amplitude and phase of the
wave at that point again it is just it
is so the coherent superposition of the
Waves emanating from those conceptual
Point sources creates the
three-dimensional wave that propagates
onwards and so on he say now the
presence of an obstacle okay now he's
going to say how it turns around the
corner right the why the cause how how
Mother Nature does this trick such as
the corner or Walt eliminate some of
those conceptual Point sources okay and
the spherical wave emanating from the
point source right at the corner
therefore propagates onward outward as a
spherical wave yeah we know that that's
a description he just saying it it is so
but he hasn't explained a single thing
and so what is the problem the big
problem here that we have with all these
people they don't know the difference
between an explanation and a description
that's what it is they say I've
explained no you haven't explained you
don't know what an explanation is that's
why you haven't expl explain and math
doesn't explain or as this uh Professor
you know Don cineman at Pennsylvania
University one of these universities
there luck Haven he said you know
science doesn't explain science
describes meaning mathematical physics
okay they don't explain they describe
and I don't know even if simonic
understands the difference between them
but at least he said look you know we
don't explain we don't tell why we don't
we can't tell you the the mechanism
that's I guess what he's saying and
people have not understood that to this
day they think that mathematical physics
is out there can explain these phenomena
they cannot they can only describe it
mathematically which is all that
mathematical physics does the
explanation coming out of the mouth of a
mathematical physics is always always
irrational always irra you will never
understand it because they're dealing
with Concept they don't deal with
objects or like that physicist so-called
physicist at the beginning why do we
have to define the word
object yeah yeah that that's the problem
for the last 10,000 years that's been a
problem why do we have to define the
word object that's why no one defined
the word object which is the first word
you need to Define in physics so that's
where the problem starts okay here's
another one it says defraction is a word
that is used to what describe correct
defraction is just a description the way
we have it today there's no explanation
that a wave of some kind encounter some
object that it cannot pass through right
that's all it is so it is so it cannot
pass for some reason or equivalently it
encounters an object that only allows it
to pass through one or more holes or
slits okay so it allows it to pass why
does it uh open up on the other side why
does why does we have these secondary
waves that are branching out and getting
bigger you know in the first case the
wave would generally bend around the
object yeah but tell me how it Bend what
caused it to bend that's what you got to
explain he says they would he's just
saying it is so in the second more
interesting example the way would create
a defraction pattern because it would
interfere with itself yeah we understand
what happens later on you know we have
the interference uh destructive and
constructive interference I need to know
why the wave turns around corners that's
the question you haven't answered that's
the one we want to answer we want to
know why if the wave is made out of
particles in the case of water you know
it's molecules right why these go
through a little slit and then
immediately widen and create this second
bigger front that's what we want to
understand right why do they open up why
don't they get narrower you know why
don't they extinguish no instead they
widen yeah that's the issue and the
question is whether water is a good
analogy for light which is what all
these people are saying when they use
when they try to explain the slit
experiment and that's a second problem
in fact a more important problem okay
here is there's a very good answer to
this in a very popular law of nature
called the what Heisenberg uncertainty
principle so he's going to look at the
fact that we don't know the position and
the motion the the momentum of a
particle that's essentially he's going
to be his argument what this principle
says is very simple at a given moment in
time you can either calculate with the
highest Precision where a particle is or
where it's moving you can never have
both okay light consists of photons I
don't know where you got that
but he's assuming their photons are
particles when you narrow the slid down
so much you know with a high Precision
in the horizontal plane where the photon
is but now when the light emerges from
it you can't be entirely sure which way
it's moving okay and so he's saying that
all these are randomly going in
different direction that's why you see a
band of light emerging on the screen
these are all possible directions that a
photon may take after he emerges from
the slid well what this fell is true
then we shouldn't see any fringes at all
we should see a single band on the I
mean why would they why would the uh uh
so-called photons you know if they're uh
if we don't know where they're going we
don't know what their um
uh momentum and location or position as
they call it is at the same time if they
are moving in any random direction if
they cannot be predicted why do they
always produce the same result you know
the fringes why do we see any fringes at
all we should have that whole I mean if
if it's just a hidden mess and the
particles are everywhere every time we
do this experiment the slit experiment
we should get the whole wall covered
with particles there should not be any
uh fringes any separation between you
know those lines and so no this guy has
not explained anything but when all else
fails where do we go to we go to the
chat GPT and this is not the chat GPT
but something similar it's another
chatbot and this is what the chatot told
uh people in Kora okay says light
deflects uh deflects at the edges of an
object due to the wave nature of light
whoa this is what the B is telling us so
you know we got to take our hats off
here when light encounters an obstacle
or passes through an aperture it bends
around the edges of the obstacle or
aperture leading to a phenomenon known
as defraction okay so far it's just a
definition of defraction you can say
it's just a description this bending of
light waves is what a result of what
interference between the waves as they
propagate through the edges leading to
the spreading of light beyond the
geometric shadow of the object yeah the
question is why do they
spread and the bot doesn't seem to
know so much for Bots you know I mean
who feeds the Bots we do right we we put
the information in there so all they did
was put the party line inside the bot's
head and the bot is just regurgitating
that this phenomenon is a fundamental
characteristic of wave Behavior that's
it and is described by the principles of
wave objects yeah in other words it is
so accept it it's the way it is and
what's the explanation well they're not
part of science they're wet philosophy
or religion or something like that okay
so how about our two Heroes uh we have
verum there Derek Muller what does he
have to say about this uh does he have
any different explanation for What's
Happening Here
let's find out listen carefully okay I'm
I'm going to do the voice okay and he's
going to do the show here it
is I have two sources of ripples which
is basically like the two
slits this pattern is created by the
ripples from the two sources interacting
with each other where they meet up peaks
with Peaks and troughs with trough the
amplitude of the wave is
increased that's what we call
constructive
interference but if the Peak from one
wave meets up with a trough from another
then we get destructive interference and
basically there's no wave there and this
is exactly what was happening with the
light okay did you get the explanation
great explanation right it is so you
know uh why the waves turned around
Corners nobody knows you know that
nobody explains that they just say it
does it is so and then the waves
interfere and they continue onwards with
something which we don't want to listen
to or hear what we want to understand
why the wave turns around the corner and
nobody can explain that especially when
they're made out of particles particles
don't turn Corners okay that's the
problem like this other fell the other
day was trying to get that through say
well you know it's by what op the law of
Optics or something like that yeah the
law of Optics yeah just this happens
that's what law means it just is
so okay and here we have the other fell
OD doubt and he says the following he
tries it with the single photons he says
if this works even with single photons
you know you shoot them and you create
the
fringes and he says we cannot explain
this we cannot explain how this happens
and yeah because you're using photons
you're using single particles that's why
you cannot explain this okay so what
this really does if you can if you're
shooting single particles and you
produce these fringes what it shows that
that you're not shooting single
particles that's the is that's the
conclusion you should reject the
particle hypothesis and instead they say
you know uh we shoot these single
photons that we're convinced and
certified with you know we we know this
for a fact we've interviewed every
single particle but for some reason
these particles you know do not
interfere because they have nothing to
inter interfere with they're just you
know individual particles being shot at
one at a time they go through the SLP
but see they go through the slit they
produce and they go in all every
direction but in every direction in
lines in a specific pattern and the
question is if this is random like this
other fellow said we should have that
whole board uh covered in pink or you
know viid um particles completely it
should be smeared and it's not it's got
these fringes and so they have explain
the fringes by saying that you know we
have to follow Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle we don't know the momentum and
position of a particle you know again
it's got nothing at all to do with the
explanation whether we know it or not
the position and
momentum okay and so what is the big
problem the big problem the more
fundamental problem here is that these
people don't understand the difference
between an explanation and a description
so let's go with the definition
scientific definitions what is a
scientific definition is the one bill
gaty proposes which a lot of people say
oh Bill you're the only one the universe
who believes in these definitions yeah
it doesn't matter doesn't matter if it's
me or whoever X could have come up with
them that's not the criteria the
criteria is objective can you use them
consistently in a
dissertation and if you cannot then your
uh definition is no good just that
simple it's just Eyes by so the fact
that you cannot defend it okay so that's
the way we do it in science we don't
raise hands and vote for definition say
well I don't like your definition I like
his definition a little more we don't
care about that can you use the
definition consistently okay that's
scientifically you know rationally okay
so here it is
description uh uh it's Timeless okay
past present future future is called
prediction right whereas explanation
only deals with the past exclusively
with the past
what's a description a listing of
properties of an object that's all the
description is for the purposes of
physics we're not talking about ordinary
speech here we use adjectives to
describe objects what's a narrative well
it's the same word but applied to um
phenomena to verbs in other words to
motion a listing usually chronological
of events that happened and we use
adverbs to qualify those okay
explanation is something totally
different explanation causes in the case
of physics or reasons and purpose in the
case of philosophy underlying a
phenomenon okay in physics which is what
we deal with here a physical
interpretation uh a mechanism underlying
a cause or to interpret the manner in
which a consummated event occurred okay
that's what a description is uh that's
why an explanation is different than a
description so those are the definitions
we propose you got better mouth trap no
problem you know throw it in show us
that you can use yours
consistently and how do we do the
bending of light well we don't bend any
light okay we do it all with straight
lines in fact all these curves uh like
the other day we were talking about the
gravitational lensing you know light
bending around you know celestial
objects such as the sun and so on now it
never happen never will light does not
Bend why because it's all made with
straight lines in the case of
gravitation lensing you have the star
which is behind the Sun and it's got all
the atoms connected to the um Corona of
the Sun and that atom in the corona of
the sun relays that same light to us so
it's all done with straight lines you
know you have these patterns that are
all done with straight lines and you can
produce curves that's the case here all
these people have confused the curvature
of light with something done with
straight lines which are the mediators
of Light which are the electromagnetic
ropes okay and here we see it that
applied to the slit experiment and how
defraction really works and here you see
an
illustrated uh before we start the
before you turn anything on what you
have is a flashlight or whatever or a
light source and uh there you can see
it's dark and it doesn't turn on until
the frequency is turned on in other
words you turned the flashlight on what
you've done is stimulated the atom so
they're pumping faster and because
they're pumping faster the they torque
the Rope at a faster rate meaning the
frequency is now higher and the link
length is lower shorter okay and so now
it comes within the visible range and
that Atom from the flashlight or Source
whatever is connected to the edges of
the needle okay if it's connected to the
edges of the needle need and those atoms
now are going to send it inwards to the
uh to the screen and that's where then
now you can have constructive and
destructive interference like I
explained the other day fact I better do
this uh by without having this there so
you can see it okay what's happening is
is this you have two ropes ah there we
go and as soon as one is offset to the
other come with respect to the other
they're do it this way
see what you're having is they're offset
okay one um link of the Rope is half a
link behind the other and then you have
all this uh in between you have uh you
know different uh Parts because you can
see that the fringes are kind of rounded
off they're not chopped off perfectly
straight and you have all these um this
range of uh of you know little by little
how the ropes are becoming more
um in L or um in other words they're um
what's the word
[Music]
um they are at the same the links are at
the same place in other words especially
the link that's hitting the atom on the
wall okay and you'll have that moving to
from Adam to atom All Along The Wall
okay from every atom one to the next
until one is half a link behind the
other and at that point you have
destructive interference because well
one rope is facing up and down the other
one is facing sideways and so at that
point one is trying to stimulate the
atom the other one is not okay so you
have this fight between the two waves
and uh the two ropes right the two links
and therefore the atom doesn't know what
to do and so it goes below uh the range
of uh of below the visible range and
that's essentially our explanation for
why you know so we're using a
wave mechanism that we we've always had
except that we don't have a wave we have
a rope that's what people have confused
the wave with all these years it was a
rope all these years a physical Rope two
twine threads and not a electromagnetic
wave which is a bunch of vectors
magnitude and Direction which is what
Maxwell came up with because again they
were all mathematicians they never
thought in terms of objects of things
and so in all of mathematical physics
for all these invisible intangent agents
we don't have a thing we only have
mathematical Concepts serving in Li of
things and so with that I will see you
next week bye-bye